Excellent!
Auf geht's
Leute ratet mal wie meine presentation heute auf der arbeit gelaufen ist was heißt auf der arbeit ich war für
40 minuten im teams call danach war ich wieder weg
Jetzt nicht so
Hört sich hört sich wild an als ist es scheiße. Nee gar nicht
Boge war das
Als ich ich erzähle euch gleich was ist natürlich wieder war es ist eine sache ist richtig in die hose gegangen also
Also im übertragenen sinne jetzt ja
Twitch money hack
Ich habe gehört der twitch money hack heißt prime subscription
Aber sowas haben wir hier nicht
Wir haben wenig primers
Also ich erzähle euch das mal kurz also
Folgendes also muss ich ein bisschen muss ich ein bisschen aus und also es war so
Ich habe heute eine präsentation auf der arbeit gehalten zu einem thema das kann ich euch so jetzt nicht sagen das ist sehr spezifisch
Aber ich kann das mal ich kann das mal umschreiben ja was welches wort hast du geguckt
Zumindest also ich kann euch ich kann euch mal das versuchen zu zu umschreiben also
Ich habe euch das schon öfters so ein bisschen erzählt was ich auf der arbeit mache beziehungsweise ich habe sogar
Komplette videos dazu aufgenommen was ich mache und seit wann und was ich verdiene und also gibt es gibt es ja alle möglichen videos
Geld überweisen mit cobalt das das wäre es ja da würde ich mir selbst ein bisschen was überweisen
Du meinst weil ich jetzt der cobalt der cobalt kenner bin seit dem letzten weihnacht stream
Zumindest habe ich einen vortrag darüber gehalten dass wir halt wie wir das machen dass wir
über 1000 linux server aktuell halten so das jetzt mal so
Und ganz grob also wie wir das wie wir das anstellen dass wird ungefähr 1000 linux systeme
regelmäßig updaten konfix anpassen aktuell halten und so dass das dann eben
Einheitlich passiert und nachvollziehbar passiert. Ich hatte auch ein paar buzzwords eingeschmissen von infrastructure as code bis zu traceability
Und so was weil sich das gut anhört
so
Und eine sache ist ist voll in die hose gegangen so ich habe team ich bin in teams call rein
kamera angeschaltet herz hat aufgesetzt
intro intro erzählt ein bisschen und auf einmal geht man herz hat aus
Hat mich keiner mehr verstanden
Also dachte ich mir so hä komisch raus aus dem call rein immer noch
Ja face liegt hier auf der arbeit wisst ihr doch wie ich aussehe ich war nicht muted ich war nicht muted teams hat einen bug
Kein kein spaß leute teams hat einen bug wenn ihr eine präsentation schert
und
Dann in das präsentationsfenster rein klickt und um mit den um mit den feiltasten die folien
vor und zurück zu machen
Dann stellt sich das default input device um
Ich habe keine ahnung warum das habe ich erst im nachhinein haben wir das so ein bisschen nachgeforscht das hat sich dann irgendwie auf
meine elgato capture card umgestellt das input device
Das hat ja nicht wirklich was gebracht
Ich ich wusste es nicht ich habe es nicht gecheckt ich habe einfach mein headset ist kaputt aber ich merke ja ob mein headset kaputt ist oder nicht
Weil ich also ich spiele
Ich habe das ja so dass ich mich selbst höre wenn ich rede ins mikrofon
Also dass ich nicht so rumschrei weil das ist ein geschlossenes headset wenn ich mich nicht selbst wieder einspielen würde würde ich hier mega rumplärren
Ist nicht so also ich habe ja gehört das ist prinzipiell nicht kaputt
Genau ich hätte dann quasi mal kurz den sound hier machen sollen
Und
Oder oder ich glaube nee nee nee leute wir sind bei einer bank ich hätte das hier machen müssen
Das war bestimmt gut angekommen das kennen sie alle
Ja zumindest ich war mal kurz hier mal update ob es irgendwas gibt zumindest headset verreckt
Weil es wie gesagt nicht headset teams teams teams komische dinge gemacht also was habe ich gemacht ich habe umgeschaltet
Auf mein iphone das hatte ja vor mir stehen mit dem iphone
Dinge gemacht also was habe ich gemacht ich habe umgeschaltet auf mein iphone
hatte ja vor mir stehen mit der kamera habe ich halt übers iphone geredet war
halt sehr pains champ weil ich habe mich dann doppelt gehört da musste ich mich
auf der einen seite immer muten dass es nicht war war war eklig leute also war
wirklich eklig dementsprechend habe ich auch die das intro total verkackt ja ich
habe ich habe intro ich habe das intro erzählt habe vollkommen vergessen dass
wir eigentlich noch mal kurz sagen wollen wer wir sind ich habe einfach
losgelegt ist mir dann aufgefallen so mitte mitten der der zweiten agenda folie
habe ich gesagt da jetzt wegen ganzen technikprobleme muss man aber müssen
wir zurück ja aber ansonsten lief das wirklich gut also ich muss sagen unter
unter druck ja also unter druck also unter unter life bedingungen klappt das
immer erstaunlich gut das ist auch der kund ich mache das ja mittlerweile sogar
gerne super super agile gewesen ja leute ich habe ich habe die basswörter
reingehauen ja agil waren wir skaliert haben
weil ich hat basswörter drinne ja wir haben wir haben wir waren traceable wir
waren agil wir waren wir haben skaliert wir an infrastructure es kaut was hatte
ich in was hatte ich in unserer grüne gut cloud und es ist ja ist ja ist ja schon
alte kamellen das wusste dass es ja geht ja also klaut geht ja nicht mehr als
basswörter ja was basswörter ist ja was was für erheiterung gesorgt hat ist der
ausdruck turnschuh administration den kannte irgendwie keiner kennt ihr das
kennt ihr den ausdruck turnschuh administration oder turnschuh admin oder
nur oder nur von meinem blöden gelaber hier ja irgendwie fanden das hatten das
voll lustig dachte eigentlich ich dachte eigentlich kennen die meisten ja damit
erst gemeint noch so die klassische art und weise irgendwas ist an der kiste
man geht ins rechenzentrum rüber weißt du man man noch aus zeiten wo
remotes nicht großartig war so nach dem motto wo man betriebssysteme noch von
dvds installiert hat und sowas ich habe halt in der präsentation ich würde
euch die präsid zeigen aber die ist halt einfach dies zu firmen bezogen kann ich
machen das sind auch sachen drin ist eindeutig für welche firma das ist ja
für welches unternehmen das ist don't cry so much dankeschön für den für den
sub muss mal kurz hochgehen aber vorher noch irgendeine frage ja und ich hatte
dazu ich habe erst mal erzählt so die klassische art und weise wenn man
linux server administriert war ja so die die turnschuh administration früher
20 wie furchtbar lustig keine ahnung und dass man da halt probleme kriegt mit
der zeit wenn einer sich mal auf einem system vertippt und du weißt nicht wo
er die probleme kommen und dass das nicht richtig skaliert und sowas in der
richtung ja und jetzt und jetzt verwendet man infrastructure es kaut
tools wenn man da besonders besonders agil und ab to date sein will man kommt
mal wieder ein video mit mit job anzeigen ja gibt's ich habe sogar schon
genug job und job anzeigen gesammelt und gescreen shorted falls die nicht mehr
gibt aber ich muss erst mal normales video aufnehmen wieder ich habe eine
riesenliste mit themen aber ich hatte die letzten tage irgendwie nicht mehr
großartig bock ich warte einfach bis das nächste sponsoring ansteht ich mache ich
mache jetzt nur noch videos wenn ich wenn sponsoring gibt also mal gucken ich
mein kleut ich war noch nie in einer wüste ich war auch noch nie irgendwie
auf einem hohen berg ich war auch noch nie am nordpol oder am südpol
wobei ja die flat earth leute sagen ja man kann ja angeblich gar nicht an den
südpol wisst ihr südpol ist ja irgendwie so eine also zum südpol kann man ja
nicht fahren erzählen die immer ja da war ich überall noch nicht also es wird
zeit wird zeit für weitere placements
nimm mal jede sponsoring an oder ist teilweise schon übelst der krab dabei
in den mobile game war letztens dabei die wollten dass ich dass ich meine
handfilme wie ich das spiele und irgendwie darauf hinweise wie süchtig
machen das spiel ist und so cringe wobei ich war noch nie in einer wüste ist auch
cringe gewesen dann war noch was war sonst noch dabei world of tanks oder world of
warplanes oder sowas ist noch dabei ich will den kram halt nicht spielen ich habe
kein problem irgendwie mal 30 60 sekunden placement in den video einzubauen
solange ich halt nicht so tun muss als würde ich spielen wenn ich es nicht
spiele was ist heute der plan sage ich gleich was zu
sage ich gleich was zu
ein blockchain hatte ich tatsächlich nicht drinne dass also blockchain hat
wirklich gar nicht reingepasst in den vortrag
don't cry so much dankeschön für den sub hatte ich glaube ich schon aber
trotzdem heute das erste mal ein rz betreten im praktikum ich verstehe jetzt
was du meinst beturnt so ja komm doch an wie groß das ist wie groß war das wo
du heute drinne warst also wie viele wie viele reihen und wie lang ist so eine
reihe ungefähr an rex gibt es gibt es aber jetzt gibt es ja von klein bis
riesig
wer ist das nicht so das laut flat earth logik der südpol eigentlich gar kein
südpol ist sondern einmal im kreis irgendwie geht und so eine eismauer ist
ach das davon darf ich heute echt nicht anfangen
ja das plan sage ich gleich mein review zu deinem sponsor spott spott letztes mal
bevor ich bevor ich fotos einklicke muss ich mir das mal anschauen
weißt du was der witz ist bei dem bei dem genchen bei dem genchen placement
was ich gemacht habe ich habe den ursprünglich 30 sekunden was ja
überzeugendes eingesprochen ja ich habe halt dann ein paar punkte genommen die
man gut in 30 sekunden packen kann oder in 60 sekunden
in 60 sekunden nicht in 30 60 30 schütze 60 sekunden packen kann und habe
da was halbwegs überzeugendes erzählt was sich auch ganz gut angehört hat das
wollten sie nicht haben sie gesagt ne ne da fehlen zu viele sachen sie haben das
kripp mal überarbeitet habe ich eine dina vierseite skript bekommen habe ich
bin ja weißt du was kriege ich ähnlich unter habe ich eineinhalb minuten das
runter gerattert musste zwar einmal lachen zwischendurch aber ok und da
haben sie gesagt ja perfekt naisu das nehmen wir also da kommt wahrscheinlich
nicht so sehr auf qualität an sondern eher dass man sich eins zu eins an das
hält was die wollen wobei das auch ein bisschen natürlich vom sponsoring
abhängt ja manche wollen so manche wollen so
riemi noch steinige für den sub so ohne scheiß so in der richtung werde ich das
auch machen wahrscheinlich ja ja das das habe ich mir auch genauso super sebi da
er meint für den zähne er wird weder sub noch sonst was aber schön dass du da
bist was er schon längst gesagt massive subscription seit 16 monaten
ich sehe dich relativ selten im chat ich meine kann jeder machen wie er will
namo sagt mir nix aber du bist schon 16 monaten monat am start das ist ja mal
richtig exzellent
richtiges boomer miem deswegen wollte ich das auch nicht aufmachen jetzt weil ich
zu wenig sellout machen muss der chat jetzt schon sellout starten
kami dankeschön für den sub ich warte immer noch auf nord vpn placement leute
nord vpn placement pass mal auf twitter wie heißt
ob wie heißt aus stuttgart die fußball der fußballverein stuttgart fußball
vfb vfb passt mal auf passt mal auf ihr werdet ihr werdet ich glaube es ab ist
es der sap du passt mal auf ihr werdet sich glauben
mist wo habe ich es wo habe ich ich will jetzt keine moment warte mal
wo habe ich es wo habe ich das zum kecken jetzt wartet mal massive keck
keck treble u ja ja ja pass mal auf
die machen werbung für nord vpn ich habe es erst nicht geglaubt als ich
gesehen habe beste cyber abwürfe vfb fans nord vpn also ganz im ernst wenn
sogar der vfb stuttgart werbung für nord vpn macht dann kann ich das auch machen
witzigerweise hat da keiner darauf geantwortet das hat ja alle nicht
interessiert ich weiß doch nicht mal was das hier
überhaupt bedeuten soll aber beste cyber abwürfe was bedeutet das überhaupt
33 bread low
sind das die die die die rücken nummern oder nee
keiner auswechsel minute oder ab ich habe keine ahnung
die spieler auf der bank meine güt das ist die tricotnummer oder wie ich habe
so keinen plan von fußball zumindest beste cyber beste cyber abwürfe vfb
fans exzellent exzellent kami dankeschön für den sub
ernsthaft wirklich sie des tibet oder hat sich das wirklich jemand runter
geladen mit dem code eingeloggt was würdet ihr für ein framework verwenden
wenn es wirklich komplett cross platform für über handy apps bis zur
des ganz im ernst also wenn er stimmt das finde ich sehr sehr nice um nicht zu
sagen also da gibt es eigentlich nur eine
möglichkeit wenn du was wirklich cross platform
mäßiges haben willst desktop und handy neben irgendwas javascript webbasiert
es ansonsten ja das gibt natürlich auch andere möglichkeiten du kannst dir
dotnen maui angucken was ich persönlich extrem furchtbar finde avalonia ist
auch cross platform cute geht theoretisch auch handy und desktop
wie du tauri läuft tauri überhaupt auf ios na gut auf ios ist eh alles safari
auch egal ob firefox oder chrome trattelt alles safari also ich vermute mal du
würdest am besten fahren mit irgendwas webbasiertem also ich meine nicht
webbasiert dass du deine anwendung nur übers internet beziehungsweise nur über
den browser benutzt machen solltest aber halt auf javascript browser technologie
so dass das eben überall läuft also das quasi in den browser in in in der
eigene app gepackt im webview ist das im endeffekt so was wie ionic oder so offen auf mobile
komplett cross platform ist tatsächlich gar nicht so einfach
ich meine flatter wäre theoretisch eine alternative allerdings muss man sagen
flatter ist auf dem desktop wiederum jetzt nicht so geil
welchen leistungskurs hattest du im abitur cute sein
das sind spiele auf der baia ja war doch richtig ich liebe anime da war das das
richtige placement für dich nein ernsthaft welche welche leistungskurse
hattest du im abitur abitur ich habe kein abitur gemacht
habe ich auch in einem video erzählt das war massive also ich aber damals das kann
man sich nicht vorstellen ich war so unglaublich faul in der
schule ich habe nichts gemacht wirklich gar nichts
ich habe ich habe noch nicht mal das mindeste gemacht und trotzdem hat es
irgendwie gereicht muss mal kurz gucken ob wir müssen glaube ich betriebssystem
neu starten dachte das verdammte spiel ja ja wir müssen wir müssen mal kurz
rebooten seck leute köln update reboot
aber die musik etwas belastend gerade
wie emoji wurde geupdatet von 1402 patch 1 ok gib ihm
was was das interessiert mich jetzt tatsächlich was wurde denn da geupdatet
wie emoji seriously wo kommt das überhaupt her tatsächlich wurde geupdatet
welcher patch kam da neue emojis dabei brauche ich neue emojis wichtig
so wir fangen gleich an aber erst einmal rebooten
ich kann euch während des reboot noch was anderes erzählen was lustiges aus
der ausbildung ist mir ist mir gerade gerade so in sinn gekommen weiß ich ob
ich euch das schon mal erzählt habe erzählt habe ist aber es ist noch was
kurzes und zwar was es teilweise für leute gibt und zwar ich hatte damals in
azubi kollege das war so eine richtig krasse disco dancer also der ist weiß
du das normalerweise hast der leute die stehen entweder rum manche die können
es nicht richtig so wie ich meist meistens aber das war so eine richtig krasse
dancer zumindest das war so ein krasser dancer wie gesagt kann sein dass ich
schon mal erzählt habe der typ wenn er irgendwo hingegangen ist wo es die
möglichkeit gab gab zu denzen der hatte so eine tasche dabei mit mit pulver
drin wahrscheinlich magnesium oder sowas und immer bevor er gedanzt hat hatte
eine runde magnesium oder so eine runde pulver auf den boden geschmissen habe
ich schon erzählt und ist darauf richtig geslide ging dann richtig ab drauf
das war dass er bessere moves machen kann das habe ich auch noch nicht gesehen
irgendwie ist mir das gerade eingefallen frag mich nicht wie ich draufkomme ich
kann sich aber noch bildlich vorstellen also ich habe vorstellen das erste was
du machst irgendwo eine runde weißes pulver auf dem boden um dann krassere
slides machen zu können
richtig giga chat ist das der nachfolger ich dachte das ist jetzt das ist das
gleiche projekt jlo ist auch da moin der hat mit dem pulver was
anderes kann ich bestimmt nicht das wäre ein bisschen teuer oh was haben wir
denn heute für den hintergrund das ist bei du immer immer das bing image of
the day messif also restore oder ein uhu wie man hier so sagt
was steht denn heute auf der agenda wer ich jetzt was zu erzählen sobald ich den
chat durchgescrollt habe oh shit war das dein package habe ich jetzt die root
shell auf meiner vm ist das mittlerweile arch der wenn man jaro als arch durchgeht
ist das arch aber nein das ist man jaro geht selbstverständlich nicht als arch
durch warum ist da kein bing watermark hier weil das bing image of the day
kein kein wasser zeichnet musst du microsoft fragen warum
so also was machen wir heute folgendes waren wir heute wir machen erst mal ein
paar tabs zu machen den browser neu auf lull also was wir heute machen ist
folgendes moment ich muss glaube ich noch mal pullen ok was
ich glaube wir haben alle keck emotes dieser welt mittlerweile guck mal
irgendwann irgendwann ist ok ok egal ich habe noch ich habe noch genug
probieren wir machen das jetzt rein ich also wenn ich noch als freien emotes lot
habe dann mache ich das rein
keck bald soll ich habe es hinzugefügt war den chat reloaden geht noch nicht
dauert wohl noch kurz aber ich habe es aktiviert dauert wahrscheinlich noch
kurz bis gesunken ist
geht noch nicht geht noch nicht
guck mal wie viele keck emotes wir haben mensch ich glaube ich muss demnächst
mal emotes aufräumen ich mein guck mal wir haben
obbei die werden alle benutzt ich glaube am wenigsten wird akt wird keck u
verwendet das benutzt glaube ich keiner
das ist eine gute idee sehr gute idee das schreibe ich mir auf
das muss ein keck sein auch auch mit so auch mit so einem zahn nebendran wie
der hier keckt ja das das benutzt eigentlich kaum einer das benutzt auch
kaum einer keck 3d benutzt auch kaum einer keck chat auch
kaum also mein ex können wir glaube ich auch wieder ein paar löschen so aber
was wir heute machen folgendes agenda exzellent gut dass ihr mich dran
erinnert chat wenn ihr mich nicht dran erinnern würdet
werde ich wahrscheinlich die hälfte eh schon wieder vergessen und wird im
stream wieder was anderes macht als eigentlich geplant hat also es gibt neue
feature requests für den fiat champ und gestern also am sonntag gab es
tatsächlich drei neue feature requests und ich habe gestern alle drei
eingebaut und ich habe festgestellt mein add-on funktioniert auch mit jeeps
wir haben den kokona request schlechthin hell yeah übrigens zum thema hell yeah
ich habe auch was tolles was was tolles kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten
rausgefunden es gibt jetzt unter android in den in den materiel also nein nicht
unter android aber die die android style icons es gibt jetzt in den material
design icons zeigt euch einfach mal hier muss ich gar nicht auf twitter zeigen
es gibt jetzt endlich kokona brothers endlich gibt es die passenden icons für
munition pistolenmagazin und rifle magazine also wer hatte in seiner app
noch nicht munition pistolen und gewährmagazin gebraucht wichtig endlich
also ich frage mich eigentlich wie in den usa überhaupt apps erstellt werden
konnten ohne dass es magazine und gewähre und so in den icons gab aber für
richtige freiheit ist das notwendig
hell yeah kokona clap 17 kommets gab seit dem letzten mal 17 kommets
holen wir mal den masterbranche mal hier was ich da alles getan hat das war
unbenutzbar sehe ich auch so also was gab es denn für feature request es gab
einmal diesen stop charging feature request den werde ich nicht einbauen
weil das unterstützt fiat nicht also was der hier haben wollte ist dass man mit
der app sein elektroauto wie wurde das mile problem gelöst zeige ich euch
gleich der wollte dass dass man das das aufladen an seinem elektroauto stoppen
kann wenn die batterie auf 80 prozent ist der hat aber die rechnung ohne fiat
gemacht weil fiat hat sich gedacht was sollen wir denn eine funktion einbauen
in unsere app zum charging stoppen es reicht wenn wir eine funktion einbauen
zum charging starten also es gibt in der fiat api keine
funktion zum stoppen des ladevorgangs man kann nur laden starten
warum weiß ich nicht weil fiat logik zumindest habe ich mir gedacht wir
könnten folgendes machen dieses ding hat die möglichkeit über ein
kalender gesteuert ladevorgänge zu stoppen und zu starten zu starten und zu
stoppen das heißt ich hätte einen fake kalender eintrag machen können von
einer minute wenn 80 prozent erreicht ist und dann wäre
wäre wahrscheinlich das charging ausgegangen
sofern der jeweilige user nicht dieses kalender feature verwendet ansonsten
hätte ich ihm was überschrieben aber das werde ich nicht implementieren das ist
zu zu hack hacky ja ich habe meine automatisierung geschickt wie ich das
mache und er sagte er kriegt bald ein ladegerät dass er in homosystem
integrieren kann dann steuer das darüber bessere idee
wir machen ein celly an die wallbox gibt es gibt es einen celly den du
gibt es nicht gibt es nicht die cellys die es gibt sind ganz normal für 230
volt maximal 16 ampere wahrscheinlich eher 10 ausgelegt und die ladeboxen an
der wand die sind ja 400 volt 16 ampere dafür gibt es wahrscheinlich kein kein
celly es gibt einen drei phasen celly ja dann
wird es wahrscheinlich funktionieren echt gibt es welchen denn
zeig mal so stimmt celly professionell
welcher denn
3em
sein energie meter das bringt mir nix wir brauchen was mit relay oder relay
wie die leute das hier sagen
das ist irgendwas celly pro 3 ja das ist doch für den schaltschrank oder ja das
bringt ja das bringt ja da draußen nix wobei man doch man könnte tatsächlich
den schaltschrank einbauen da drüber ja aber ganz im ernst das ist das ist
plötzlich nicht das muss eine ordentliche ordentliche ladegerät muss
die möglichkeit haben remote an oder auszuschalten alles andere ist ist doch
krepp im celly das dahin und her schalten ist doch büll das ist doch nix
also würde ich auch keine keinem empfehlen
doch doch doch du hast recht ja ja das kann mit sicherheit passieren
wahrscheinlich hast du probleme mit dem entriegeln des kabels es sei denn dass
das macht irgendwie automatisch entriegelt sobald wenn es ausgeht und
hast es da drin stecken gut am auto kriegste sie immer raus ich
habe meine wallbox e-standard mäßig verriegelt das blödsinn ich brauchte
eine die ausschalten kann alles andere ist doof so also das hat mir das erste
also das das werde ich nicht das werde ich nicht umsetzen so dann gab es noch
ein weiteres issue was ich gestern implementiert habe nämlich kilometer
ich zeige euch erst mal das hier kilometer zu meilen umrechnen weil hell
yeah kecona weiter
ja habe ich ihm geschrieben was sache ist und hier habe ich das habe ich das
eingebaut das haben wir auch versucht dem stream zu bauen das werde ich euch
gleich zeigen wie ich das gebaut habe also kilometer zu meilen umrechnen haben
wir drinne und dann kam noch jemand mit einem jeep um die ecke mit einem jeep
wrangler 4 xe bisschen verschenkt dass ich xd ist xe wahrscheinlich weil es
elektrik ist
leute ich gucke gerade nicht so wirklich in chat wenn was in ist schreibt
entwobblos davor dann sehe ich das so er hat gesagt es geht nicht mit dem jeep
das erste was ich festgestellt habe ist
er hat seinen mqtt server nicht richtig eingerichtet das war das erste was
gefixt werden musste und das nächste ist er hat die werte nicht gefunden habe ich
ihm gesagt wo er die werte findet und easy siehe da es hat einfach out of the
box funktioniert und er ist der erste der mal versucht hat sein auto fern zu
steuern und das hat auch funktioniert also schon mal ganz gut so bleiben jetzt
nur folgende issues offen
das da also es gibt es gibt tatsächlich noch ein bisschen mehr aber also das
da gibt es einmal noch wo wir uns heute ein bisschen drum kümmern werden das ist
aber easy zu fixen kann ich auch gleich sagen das ist eigentlich schon gefixt
ich habe support eingebaut dass man einen externen mqtt broker verwenden kann wenn
man nicht in eingebauten es gibt jetzt so einen schalter im web front end dass
man sagen kann ich möchte mqtt settings überschreiben und dann kann man seinen
eigenen broker eingeben sofern dass der broker ist den home assistant verwendet
sonst funktioniert es nicht so also das habe ich eingebaut dann hatte noch
irgendwelche anderen probleme gehabt genau und dadurch dass das über den
externen mqtt broker geht ist das problem dass home assistant das nicht
schnell genug verarbeiten kann also der exportiert die sensoren an home
assistant wartet 200 millisekunden und dann published er gleich den neuesten
sensor state das problem ist dass home assistant wenn es wenn es einen sensor
state bekommt während es den sensor an sich noch nicht mal verarbeitet hat dann
macht es einfach gar nichts deswegen wahrscheinlich müssen wir
einfach das lieb hier ein bisschen länger machen dass es funktioniert gibt
leider keine andere möglichkeit außer den sleep hier zu machen wie kam es
eigentlich zu deinem nicknames es hat kein super spannende story ich habe den
account erstellt und musste irgendwas eingeben ich wollte selbst nicht
streamen zu dem zeitpunkt und dann habe ich es einfach genommen zum zum stream
geht das mit ferraris das kommt darauf an ob die eine api haben also mit dem
addon selbst wird das nicht funktionieren es sei denn die verwenden
uconnect die gleichen sachen die fiat verwendet die haben bestimmt eigene
api das funktioniert nicht weil ich kann ja schlecht bei fiat was abfragen von
einem anderen hersteller jeep dotch oder so das ist so ein kokona ami ding und
fiat die verwenden bei allen drei die gleichen services deswegen funktioniert
das für chrysler gibt es glaube ich eine integration in home assistant wenn ich
das richtig richtig weiß das ist auch uconnect das ist auch uconnect
da besteht die chance dass es funktioniert ja ja das muss man
ausprobieren das muss man auch nicht vorwärts fahren was da los ich habe es
genau gesehen wo da vorn was da los
bonkers genau ich habe es genau gespottet
als anscheinend nichts
also das könnte sein dass das funktioniert also alles was uconnect
verwendet könnte sein dass es funktioniert heute ich habe einen
vorschau stream ich sehe dass es nicht f ist das war ja wirklich eines der
schlechtesten jebait versuche die ich je gesehen habe das war negativ jebait
moin präsent was heute gehen wir bauen wir fixen auch ein paar
sachen und bauen neue neue sachen ein neues feature ein ja also das musste
mal ausprobieren ob das funktioniert wenn ich uconnect verwenden kann sein
dass es funktioniert wenn es nicht funktionieren sollte
kannst du mich mal anschreiben im discord dann können wir nämlich zusammen
gucken es ist auch kein ton weg immer zu massiv huge negativ tibet
dann können wir gucken ob wir das eingebaut kriegen
dann müsstest du aber was capturen auf der webseite für mich und mit den output
schicken damit ich das sehe wie es da aussieht
chat
weird jam ja das kann sein ja mach mach mal dann sag Bescheid wenn
er da ist kannst du innerhalb von 14 tagen zurück an amazon schicken
gut ich weiß was leute ich mache mir den patreon account das ist es ich mache
mir den patreon account und da müssen alle alle patreonen damit ich mir ein
ferrari als testauto kaufen kann für meine add-on entwicklung
onlyfans quatsch hänseli wenn schon onlyfans ist mal richtig fänzli leute
hänseli
gachi bass da kennt sich wer aus ja du weißt ja anscheinend auch worum es geht
natürlich muss da schon bescheid wissen
da müsste ich die face warum müsste ich face liegen
ich kann auch ein video zu meinem auto aufnehmen ohne festzulegen
genau so also weiter geht es so dass das das tatsächlich jetzt alles
erklärt und da gibt es noch ihn hier der der will ob man nicht die meilen also
wieder first world kokona issues ob man nicht die meilen etwas besser runden
kann vielleicht auf zwei stellen und so was in der richtung wobei das relativ
easy sein sollte so und dann kommt das größte was wir einbauen müssen was es
gar nicht als feature request gibt nämlich ich werde euch das mal kurz
demonstrieren moment hier mal hier rein
ok gut face liegt man ks hast du wo ist das
face liegt chain law ich kenne das video zeigt mal hier wie gut das face
liegt ist damals massif alda da ist er sieht ein bisschen ich muss sagen sieht
ein bisschen monac s aus ein bisschen bisschen monac es aber das beste ohne
scheiß ich sehe ein bisschen aus wie dance gaming hier ich sehe in echt
tatsächlich also ich finde ich sehe dance gaming relativ ähnlich wobei ich
glaube mittlerweile bin ich in der ecke dünner als dance gaming 2013 ja was war
auf das beste liegt ist aber immer noch suppe max in der picking suppe das ist
immer noch das beste liegt
das ist wirklich ein foto was ich gepostet aber auf twitter wo ich mit dem
kabum china chinesen kram futtern war hat irgend einer gedacht er muss jetzt
mich rekonstruieren aus der suppe
ja google ist der meinung wer auch immer das ist aber ich bin es nicht was ich
angeblich alles bin max war auch öfters in ulm das korrekt ja vielleicht bin ich
damals schon dem er noch tricks über den weg gelaufen weiß es nicht das ist
hadith von piz mit ok ich wie gesagt ich kenne die ganzen leute nicht
gut weiter geht es ja es gibt es gibt noch ein weiteres problem ich muss mal
kurz mein mein demo home assistant anmachen damit wir das damit ihr euch
das zeigen kann also es gibt ein problem und zwar folgendes ich gehe mal kurz auf
meine home assistant instanz und zeige euch das hoch was war das hat es einen
fehler gegeben gerade beim starten also home assistant 8123 home assistant da
sind wir unit miles value oje das ist immer noch kaputt integrations mqtt
prokka alternativ hätten wir auch noch keckel def best namen für die devices
da weißt du bescheid so habe ich alles im chat durch was zockste overwatch 2 nein
ich habe ehrlich gesagt wenig bock auf overwatch muss ich ehrlich muss ich
ehrlich sagen das stimmt hier mit der größe nicht oder
chat wie groß hatten wir den chat immer so ich glaube wir hatten ihn sogar so
immer oder gott hat verwirrt
elotrix immer noch im jacuzzi mit 40 frauen
ja heute ist das top streamer massif money wahrscheinlich noch mehr
hat er nicht ganz offiziell irgendwie letzten sogar seine freundin irgendwie im
stream vorgestellt oder sowas na gut ich mein das hält ja jemand nicht davon ab
im pool mit 40 medels zu setzen und mit wie war das 20 zentimeter deutsch im
stahl was auch immer für ein blödsinn früher erzählt hat reicht für mehrere
was ein schwachsinn alter
ach quatsch warum ich kann das doch ab und zu mal sagen was wir tun ist
programmiert wir bauen neue features ein in meinen add-on für für
home assistant für elektroautos davon distanziert er sich aber heutzutage
ernsthaft tatsächlich da frage ich mich ich weiß nicht vielleicht verfolgt ihn
einfach interessiert wie ist das distanziert er sich davon weil ihm das
irgendein marketing mensch geraten hat oder fand er das doch etwas übertrieben
so persönlich schwer zu sagen keine ahnung ich wie gesagt ich verfolge die
streams nicht
ich fand ja damals auch einiges ein bisschen gar gar grenzwertig aber gut
der vier champ weiter geht's also es gibt ein problem und das ist eigentlich
das größte das größte größten back dem heute fixen müssen bzw wo wir was
einbauen müssen nämlich euch fällt vielleicht auf
car location ist unbekannt normalerweise sollte car location sein home oder away
oder home und not home dass man nämlich anhand dieses sensors erkennen kann ob
das auto auf dem hof steht oder nicht das ist verbackt was heißt verbackt
nicht eigentlich funktioniert wie gedacht oder wie gemacht nein es
funktioniert wie es implementiert ist aber es ist schlecht durchdacht so rum
er meint heutzutage wird einem alles verboten nimmt alles zu jetzt also da bei
einem punkt gebe ich auf jeden fall recht es wird heute viel zu viel viel zu
ernst genommen ja und sich über viel zu viel viel zu früh und viel zu viel
empört ja das sehe ich ganz genauso verboten ja gesetzlich nicht aber wenn
du pesch hast hast halt den twitter cancel mob am start der dir das leben
zur hölle macht also insofern ja ist schon was dran
also heute hätte das nicht mal machen können mit den videos da die wend
komplett komplett eskaliert alle tweet ist raus
so wo sind wir jetzt stehen also was funktioniert ist die läng grad breiten
grad funktioniert aber was nicht funktioniert ist home und not home die
sache ist die eigentlich weiß der home assistant wo er steht kann ich euch
zeigen nämlich in den settings ach ja übrigens ihr müsst gar nicht auf die
idee kommen das jetzt zu suchen das sind das ist fake ja das ist irgendwo im
was irgendwo im arabischen mehr oder so war das haben wir am letzten auf google
maps geguckt irgendwo mitten im wasser ist diese diese koordinate hier so der
home assistant weiß ja eigentlich wo er steht der steht nämlich in tja standort
bearbeiten in amsterdam wapen nation
ja
in kann ich aussprechen so da steht der home assist als der home assistant weiß
wo er steht und mein sensor weiß wo das auto ist das heißt eigentlich sollte
der feststellen können ob er home oder nicht home ist aber so funktioniert das
ganze nicht home assistant checkt das nicht selbst wenn du quasi sagst ich
möchte die werte selbst einliefern da musste auch selbst ein liefern ob home
oder nicht home weil es könnte ja durchaus sein dass du ein sensor hast
der was anderes liefern soll das heißt wir müssen den sensor so umbauen dass
der checkt das wird tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter der sensor muss
folgendes machen er muss von home assistant abrufen
wo der home assistant steht und dann muss er das vergleichen mit dem
längen und breiten grad wo das auto sich gerade befindet und anhand das
dessen dann also sagen wir mal so in einem kilometer radius um home wird das
auto als home angezeigt ansonsten not home das ist tatsächlich komplizierter
mal gucken wie wir das machen prinzipiell weiß ich schon ich habe mir
das natürlich im vorfeld angeguckt und mal auch eine home assistant response
mitgeschnitten dass ich weiß wie es oder ein api api request aussieht also das
fixen wird dass man erkennen kann ob sein auto daheim ist oder nicht plus das mit
den mit dem runden und dem und dem delay und sowas das können wir auch das
können wir auch alles noch fixen
ja das war es ich würde sagen wir fangen jetzt mal kurz nochmal an mit dem
was wir im letzten stream gemacht haben letztes stream habe ich versucht das hier
einzubauen habe es aber im stream nicht so ganz auf die reihe gekriegt
ich wollte die umrechnung machen von kilometer zu meilen so und das
funktioniert folgendermaßen ich es ist relativ übersichtlich ja also das ist
256 zeilen so im main also da pickt man da pickt man schon durch also der
ablauf der ablauf ist relativ easy ich gehe jetzt einfach noch mal schnell
drüber und dann sehen wir auch wie das mit mit meilen konvertieren und so
funktioniert also dass das das komplette main von dem von dem gesamten
erlauben sagt man bist du max von youtube ich bin wo bloß
wie kommst du da drauf ich habe das logo nur geklaut weil ich max fbs fern bin
das ist nicht blazing lieferst written in rastia auf reporten report ist raus
es aber schön dass du deinen weg her gefunden hast wie hast du es denn
gefunden wurde es dir empfohlen auf twitch oder hast du auf youtube geklickt
nicer helm hast du auf youtube den channel angeklickt oder war das irgendwie
den empfehlungen drinnen ich habe nämlich festgestellt dass sie ja ohne
mist hast du irgendwas mit technik am hut hast du irgendwas mit programmieren
servoren services internet web designe so irgendwas zu tun oder oder würdest du
andere hat es einfach so empfohlen weil ich habe das jetzt schon ein paar mal
gemerkt ich habe keine ahnung ob die irgendwie analytics oder so austauschen
ich habe das schon ein paar mal gemerkt dass irgendwelche empfehlungen kommen
weil leute auf youtube gucken das kann doch eigentlich gar nicht sein als
overwatch enjoyer wurdest du mir empfohlen ich habe mal irgendwann
overwatch gestreamt aber das wird es wahrscheinlich keine ahnung also
irgendwas irgendwas ist da im busch was analytics angeht
hey max ich war gerade bei den koordinaten schönes auto nice dass dir
gefällt was aber schnell
echt sagt ist overwatch 2 lull wer weiß was jetzt da wieder treibt also ich
erkläre jetzt mal ganz kurz wie das add-on funktioniert so schnell durchgang
zwei drei minuten für alle nicht die nicht die nicht die letzten streams dazu
gesehen habe also das ganze ist ein home assistant add-on wie man hier sieht
das ist ein home assistant add-on ganz endlich fiat champ und da kann man dann
seine login daten von fiat hinterlegen password und pin wie oft man die daten
aktualisieren will plus noch ein paar andere geschichten und dann bekommt man
diese werte hier zurück von von der fiat api das ist keine offizielle fiat api
das ist quasi die api die auch die app verwendet von fiat die gibt es aber
offiziell nicht also sie haben keine offiziellen api docs und dementsprechend
beschissen lässt sie sich auch für bedienen aber man kann einfach so tun
als wäre man die app und kann den kram abfragen das funktioniert so und da
kriegt man dann beispielsweise den standort vom auto geliefert oder eben wie
viel meilen noch bis die batterie leer ist ob der ladestecker eingesteckt ist
und so was in der richtung genau so das funktioniert folgendermaßen ganz
normale prinzipie ist es dort net konsole anwendung hier stehen hier stehen die
settings drin der lock ein bisschen was am anfang dann baut eine verbindung zu
fiat auf baut eine verbindung zum mqtt server auf connectet sich ruft das habe
ich noch drin das kann ich eigentlich mal wieder rausschmeißen das habe ich
noch drin weil es auf dem raspberry pi random mal irgendwie viel ramp verbraucht
hat was es aber nicht mehr macht eigentlich soll man es ja gar nicht
machen ist eigentlich verpönt garbage collector von hand zu collecten das
soll man ja nicht letztendlich ist es teilweise gar nicht mal blöd das zu
machen je nachdem was was man da macht aber jetzt da sagen die ja alle immer
gar nicht collector manuell collecten soll man nicht machen aber eigentlich
ist es auch nicht schlimm jetzt an der stelle so dann lockt er sich ein
war fiat guckt dass es die session nicht abläuft und dann ruft er von fiat über
die ap also das ist eigentlich gekapselt über diese klasse ruft das alle autos ab die man
in diesem fiat account registriert hat
hier und macht eine schleife drüber die meisten leute werden nur ein auto
registriert haben aber man mehrere autos hat dann kann man auch mehrere autos
darüber im gleichen account verwenden also ruft alle autos ab und dann legt
er sensoren für home assistant an und schreibt dann dort die werte die er von
fiat abgefragt hat rein und dann dann pusht er diesen ganzen krempel zu
home assistant und das war es dann fängt er wieder von vorne an wenn es
fehler gab meist schreibt er was ins lock und ansonsten fängt er wieder von
vorne einer eine viertel stunde so man kann auch commands an sein auto schicken
da gibt es dann so commands wie zum beispiel sehr sprechend sehr sprechend
alles bei fiat gibt es dann commands zum beispiel wie habelf was glaube ich
blink blink leitz oder irgendwie sowas heißt habelf oder rdu und rdl und rotz
rot an lock und rat an lock alles klar da muss man halt wissen was das heißt
ansonsten ist man verloren weil fiat hat das nicht für möglich für
notwendig gehalten dass das irgendwie sprechend sein muss aber gut müssen die
auch nicht weil die ja selbst hoffentlich wissen was sie machen und
ansonsten sollte das hier eigentlich normalerweise keiner verwenden ja dann
kann man commands schicken da braucht man die pin die man sonst eingibt im in
der app und dann kann man beispielsweise auch den batteriestatus refreshen
lassen oder man kann location über gps updaten batteriestatus refreshen
lassen lichter blinken lassen habelf das charging starten vom auto den
kofferraum aufmachen die klimaanlage ein oder ausschalten
wobei moment moment moment man kann die klimaanlage anschalten man kann die
klimaanlage nicht ausschalten weil die bei fiat gedacht haben wer möchte schon
klimaanlagen ausschalten kann die klimaanlage standardmäßig nur
einschalten nicht ausschalten ich habe in den android in der android app im
source code ich habe die android app die
compiled of stream und stream darf man sowas ja nicht machen
ich habe da ein json file gefunden in dem json file stehen alle remote commands
drin und es gibt auch ein remote command zum klimaanlage ausschalten
allerdings ist die sache halt die also dass das ist pro precont of ist das
command zum klimaanlage ausschalten das ist aber dangerous weil ich habe alles
als dangerous markiert was entweder offensichtlich dangerous ist zum
beispiel remote die tür auf und zu machen oder alles was nicht supported ist
von der offiziellen app
genau ja
so sieht das ganze aus aber kurz die sachen beantworten aus dem chat wie
verbindet er zum fiat ok ich dachte eigentlich in dem detail ich zeige ich
zeige es trotzdem noch mal er verbindet zum fiat folgendermaßen
fiat fake client das funktioniert folgendermaßen der hat die
ich habe die ganzen api urls hier die man bei fiat braucht also zum beispiel
outs sdpr-1fcagcv.com obviously eine fiat domain cringe wer nicht erkennt dass
das eine fiat domain ist so solche geschichten also ich habe die ganzen ich
habe mir die ganzen domains rausgesucht die man braucht witzigerweise funktionieren
diese domains für jeep anscheinend auch weil der eine typ hat ja dann ein ticket
aufgemacht bei mir die wird für jeep nicht gehen und dann ist doch
funktioniert hatte mit so kann ich ja gleich was zu erzählen falls falls ich
weiß ich lese gleich so api keys die sind eh schon public leaked das verrate
ich ihr nichts geheimes so und dann lockt er sich ein mit also man braucht
password und user von seinem fiat account dann habe ich eingestellt dass
standardmäßig dreimal retried bevor er einen fehler meldet so und dann versucht
er sich einzuloggen eigentlich relativ straight forward
er geht zu der login url und übergibt den api key bekommt dann irgendeinen
token dann geht er noch mal zu login url mit dem token übergibt username
password irgendwelche magic parameter dann holt er sich eine json web token
dann artificiert er sich bei aws amazon kriegt in amazon identity token und
damit kann ich dann weitere request schicken also das ist eklig das ist ich
weiß nicht was ich vier dabei gedacht hat aber gut das es ist ein bisschen
abartig ja und dann so lockt er sich bei fiat ein und damit die session nicht
abläuft damit die session nicht abläuft hatte im hintergrund ein task der alle
zwei minuten sich neu einloggt und ich habe das so gemacht dass die session
sich überschneidet also sprich meine session läuft fünf minuten aber ich
refresche sie alle zwei minuten das heißt wenn jemand gerade zufälliger
weise was ausführt während die session refreshed ist es nicht schlimm weil die
alten session informationen die gelten weiterhin
mosquito bang bang also wenn du was genaues wissen willst kann ich dir das
schon zeigen ich habe es absichtlich jetzt so durch durch gerattert damit wir
was was basteln können noch übrigens wer es nicht kennt das ist eine neue
timer klasse in dort net dort net hat ja irgendwie 14 verschiedene timer
klassen und es gibt jetzt ein neuer eine neue
timer klasse seit dem letzten dotnet release weil sich microsoft gedacht hat
wir brauchen nur 15 eine timer klasse nur mit dem unterschied dass die das
erste mal gescheit gemacht ist
selfer und moin lange nicht gesehen was wir machen ja hier wird nicht das
pentagon lahm gelegt hier werden daten von meinem elektroauto abgerufen guck
sieht dann so aus kann es mal zeigen ich kann daten von meinem auto abrufen und
mir dann so ein dashboard davon bauen ja zum beispiel sowas wie reifendruck
vorne links hinten rechts ok ich kann die klimaanlage heizung ein und
ausschalten licht remote ein ausschalten die batterie ladung mir
angucken farten lock standort auf einer karte kilometerzähler
batteriestatus und solche geschichten alles äsing fast fast alles doch nee nee
tatsächlich mehr oder weniger alles äsing hast recht
das gibt es nicht vom hersteller ja und nein also es gibt vom hersteller eine
app und es gibt vom hersteller ein webservice wo man sich manche sachen
davon angucken kann das problem ist nur dass der webservice nur daheim
funktioniert beziehungsweise nur wenn du am rechner bist am browser und
eingeloggt bist und die app ist shit also das ist eines der ekligsten apps die ich
hier bedient habe wenn man jetzt quasi da sein auto ordentlich integrieren will
auch in seinen heimautomaten sein heimautomation system da bleibt ihr
nichts anderes übrig als quasi diese die inoffizielle schrittstelle von fiat
da anzuzapfen also sprich das was sie normalerweise mit ihrer app selbst
verwenden kann man ja auch so ansprechen und sich die daten ziehen dann kann man
das in seine heimautomatisierung integrieren das sieht dann zum beispiel
so aus ein ganz gutes beispiel jetzt stop charging da kann man nämlich so was
machen aber geht das so easy ist das open source
meins ist open source das kannst du dir auf github angucken hier wo bloß
fiat champ die app ist natürlich nicht open source aber glücklicherweise konnte
ich mir zum größten teil nicht alles aber zum größten teil konnte ich mir von
einem anderen projekt abgucken nämlich einmal e v cc und
irgendwas mit i o broker i o broker fiat das haben zwei leute schon gebaut
war einer anderen programmiersprache ich konnte mir die api aufrufe angucken ja
und wenn du das in deine heimautomatisierung integriert hast
kannst du zum beispiel solche geschichten machen wie alle 15 minuten nachgucken
ob dein ladegerät noch lädt also das das war so unter wallbox läuft
normalerweise ob dein ladegerät noch lädt wenn ja dann neuen batteriestatus abrufen
vom auto so dass es sich quasi immer aktualisiert und dann wenn das auto
fertig geladen ist dann aktualisiert noch mal den batteriestatus wartest 30
sekunden und schickst dir eine nachricht aufs handy wo drinne steht auto fertig
geladen hat fünfeinhalb stunden gedauert und das alles ohne dass man
irgendwelche hersteller apps verwenden muss und es geht einfach so mit allem
was man verwenden will ja also meins ist open source und auf github aber die app
natürlich nicht so da habe ich das gezeigt wie er zu fiat verbindet was
ist denn wenn du den einschalten befehl einmal schickst gegebenenfalls ist das
ein switch command zweites mal schickst dann ist es eben also es gibt zwei
sachen es gibt switches und es gibt buttons und was was ist siehst du hier so
also update location ist ein button den kannst du einfach nur drücken egal ob
an oder aus kofferraum auf und zu das ist ein switch siehst du auch im
home assistant wenn du guckst das ist ein switch kofferraum auf und zu das ist
ein switch es geht jetzt nicht weil ich das
programm nicht laufen ab das ist das ist ein switch der geht an wenn man das
erste mal drückt geht er dann auch zu so einem schalter hin und her
ich meine damit die klimaanlage einschalten zweimal schicken geht dir
dann nicht nee nee die geht nicht aus ein und ausschalten sind unterschiedliche
unterschiedliche befehle zum beispiel das mit der klimaanlage sieht folgendermaßen
aus er sendet erst also wenn der switch auf
geht dann setzt dann sendet er das kommando zu fiat roprekont und wenn man
das switch wenn man den switch nochmal klickt nochmal ausschaltet dann sendet
er roprekont auf und mal angenommen du klickst ultra schnell was eigentlich
nicht geht weil das frontend ordentlich programmiert ist von home assistant
aber mal angenommen schaffst es wirklich zweimal dieses kommando
hintereinander zu senden passiert nichts dann bleibt sie einfach an wenn wir uns
sehen wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich in 100 jahren nicht mehr
wir haben uns mal glaubt wir haben uns das letzte mal gesehen irgendwie vor zehn
jahren oder so acht jahre ist schon ein bisschen so was gibt es dann sonst noch
für questions ja jetzt ewig her weiß so zufälliger
weiß wie man in hr den state von einem heizungsthermometer speichern wieder
setzen kann es kommt auf die integration an wenn
es mqtt ist musst du die message als retained einstellen dann wird das im
mqtt broker gespeichert und ansonsten hängt es von einem addon ab beziehungsweise
integrationen du hast homatic ip und wie kommt
homatic ip an home assistant über mqtt oder mit einer eigenen integration wenn
es mit einer eigenen integration ist dann musst du hoffen dass die integration
das kann
also mit mqtt oder mit das motor ist es beispielsweise einfach das motor kann
selbst sagen zurückwechsel in den eigenen in den letzten stand vom stromausfall
also es gibt den home assistant die möglichkeit dass du ein default
default status setzt für sensoren aber das sind eigentlich nicht sensoren die
von der integration angelegt werden du könntest du könntest eine
automatisierung machen die beim home system startup einmal initial value
setzt aber das alles nicht schön das muss man sich im detail angucken gibt es
auch teilweise schon kann man den reifen noch nicht auch über rtl für
in dem fall nicht das geht das geht nur über mobil funk da ist eine simkarte im
auto drin ja genau das ist im kater drin
improved wenn ich habe von homatic keine ahnung ich kann dir wirklich nichts zu
sagen keine ahnung also dann nur sagen wie es mit der mqtt integration ist so
leute so funktioniert das ganze das heißt wir fangen jetzt mal mit was
einfachem an ach so ich wollte euch ja noch zeigen wie das mit den meilen
konvertieren gemacht ist das ist tatsächlich ziemlich easy gemacht
beziehungsweise die naheliegendste art und weise und zwar seit der letzten
version gibt es ja die möglichkeit für unsere kakona us user
kilometer in meilen konvertieren zu lassen dafür gibt es jetzt ein
ein button im config menü kann man sagen hier konvert kilometer to miles und das
sieht dann so aus wenn das das umgerechnet hat so das funktioniert
folgendermaßen und zwar an dieser an der stelle das ist ich gebe zu es könnte
durchaus schöner sein es könnte re-fact dort werden mal eine eigene eine
eigene methode dass es hier nicht so drin rumgammelt aber jetzt ist es halt so
wie es ist gibt es eigentlich einen mock service für die fiat api ja gibt es
kannst du dir bei mir auf github angucken wenn du willst hier es gibt den
fiat client fake
der schickt fake responses da siehst du wieso was aussieht
da siehst du wie die wie die wie so was ausschaut was fiat fiat zurückschickt
fake gemmock dem mock gemm also der guckt nach ob der also muss ich
anders erzählen also alle werte die über die fiat api zurückkommen landen
im endeffekt in diesem dictionary das ist ein string string dictionary also
string key string value besteht im endeffekt aus einer zusammenhängt also
im prinzip ist das hier ist der key und das hier ist der value das muss ich so
machen damit der sensor einzigartig heißt ansonsten würde das nämlich
einfach nur value heißen und ich kann ich 500 value sensoren exportieren so
weiß man ungefähr was es ist und es ist einzigartig also der guckt ob der key
von diesem wert also von diesem wert hier mit value endet ich weiß halt nicht was
fiat alles schickt das könnte morgen schon wieder ein bisschen mehr sein ein
bisschen was anderes das heißt ich habe keinen wirklichen keine klasse jetzt für
diese kommt für diese kompletten werte ich habe für die sachen die sich nicht
ändern eigene klassen wo ich mein jason deserie leisten kann aber für
diesen ewig langen output nicht das heißt ich muss das der reihe nach
durchgehen also ich gucke ob der wert mit value aufhört dann ist es eventuell was
was ich konvertieren will ich schaue ob es entsprechend zu diesem value ein
weiteren key gibt was gut self und der die unit enthält sollte das der fall
sein dann gucke ich ob im user interface
convert kilometer to miles gesetzt ist und ob diese unit kilometer ist weil es
gibt ja noch andere units in dem was fiat antwortet ja paskal und reifendruck und
so geschichten also er guckt soll ich konvertieren und ist die unit kilometer
wenn ja dann passt er die kind den kilometer value als int und rechnet ihn
mal 0,62137 weil massif miles umrechnung
so dann setzt er die unit auf mi weil miles und schreibt in den sensor rein
anstatt den kilometer wert eben den miles wert so und dann macht er noch ein
bisschen magic das habe ich auch eingebaut dass manche sachen bisschen
schöner aussehen wenn die unit volts ist dann setzt er die unit vom sensor auf v
weil homos ist in das markt und setzt auch ein icon nämlich so einen strom
eiken für den sensor ja wenn es null oder null ist dann ist die unit leerer
string und ansonsten ist es eben die unit die fiat zurück liefert in dem
sensor und das war es das ist die umrechnung zum eil
also das was ich letztes mal im stream auch probiert habe aber bis mir ein
bisschen schwer getan habe dies am besten einbau eigentlich relativ nah
liegend wie es jetzt wie es jetzt ist so womit fangen wir denn jetzt an ich
will sagen wir fangen mit dem allereinfachsten an weil das wahrscheinlich
nur eine zeile ist guck mal wir fixen das hier easy easy fix fünf in fünf
minuten
wir machen das jetzt tiny issue braucht auch nur tiny tiny anpassung wir machen
tiny tiny tiny round machen wir jetzt math round auf zwei stellen easy fertig
mehr müssen wir nicht machen alles gut abgehakt
next das ist visual basic und wenn ich jetzt jetzt bin ich gerade verwirrt war
das javascript oder dotnet sekunde zu fix das war javascript oder ja ja
unit test wird testet heutzutage schon keck es gibt es gibt einfach die leute
die nicht fehlerfrei programmieren können die müssen testen aber wenn wir
so wie wie wir und der chat auch meiner chat man das überträgt sich ja hier auf
den chat wenn man wie wir hier im stream prinzipiell fehlerfrei programmiert
braucht man selbstverständlich auch keine tests und wisst ihr was noch viel
besser ist man braucht auch keine dokumentation weil was will man
dokumentieren wenn es gleich vom ersten mal fehlerfrei funktioniert ist logisch
überlegt euch mal wie agil man dann sein kann und wie viel zeit man spart wenn
man einfach fehlerfrei programmiert first try every time einfach machen leute
einfach machen just just fehlerfrei und in russ ist es dann auch
blazingly fast und du musst auf jeden fall auf deine github seite schreiben
blazingly fast written in rust ruined ruined talmo sechs monatangst für den
sub channel ist wieder äußerst wierd schämpig unterwegs zu gar sango
danken schön messen subscriptions hier leute danken schön die ganzen subs
massive subs uml dass das überlasse ich euch uml die akram easy
so sieht es aus ja ok machen wir mal das hier machen wir mal das nächste das
nächste dürfte auch relativ easy sein und mal kurz klohsen wieder alles
das hier dürfte tatsächlich auch relativ einfach sein der hat jetzt noch das
problem dass sein haub assistant zu über den extern mqtt broker zu langsam
ist und ich habe mir gedacht wir können das folgendermaßen machen aktuell werden
die sensoren an haub assistant hier an der stelle angelegt der announced den
sensor das sieht dann so aus dass es hier haub assistant jason geschwuppel das
muss man so senden damit haub assistant das versteht der announced den sensor
und dann published er gleich den state ich habe schon einen kleinen sleep
eingebaut weil es nicht anders funktioniert man kann nicht warten bis
haub assistant fertig ist also sprich der sagt haub assistant es gibt jetzt
diesen sensor zum beispiel hier den da diesen location sensor oder was auch
immer es gibt jetzt einen neuen sensor sagte haub assistant und dann 200
millisekunden später pusht er schon haub assistant den wert für diesen sensor
das problem ist das wenn es hier dazwischen haub assistant noch nicht
chain law willst du wieder gebannt werden mod check heute wieder ist wieder
wahnsinn was man hier alles was man hier alles machen soll
pfeiffer programming actions und danebenbei muss man noch leute im chat
verwarnen
weg
so und wenn das hier dazwischen länger dauert als 200 millisekunden da gibt es
ein problem weil haub assistant hat den sensor noch nicht angelegt und
dementsprechend kannst du auch keinen neuen state schicken man könnte jetzt
die nuke variante machen task delay einfach noch mal 500 millisekunden aber
das macht das ganze relativ langsam er macht es zwar parallel aber trotzdem bei
jedem 500 millisekunden ist glaube ich nicht so sinnvoll was ist in parallel
drin das verstehe ich jetzt nicht genau was das hier das macht der pro oder was
meint oder du meinst was hier in diesem parallel name space drinne ist oder in
dieser parallel class class drinne ist oder was genau
ok also wie gesagt schreibt mal was du genau wissen willst also das hier ist
ein eingebautes feature im framework was unter der haube quasi guckt wie viele
cpus hast du und dann startet es quasi für jede cpu einen eigenen task und so
was da gibt es da gibt es noch mehr ich zeig dir vielleicht ist das das was du
wissen willst ja du kannst was ist in vogue
habe ich noch nicht verwendet es gibt vor vor each und vor each async also sprich
du kannst normale schleifen zum zählen machen du kannst vor each schleifen
machen aber halt so dass das ohne dass du dich selbst darum kümmern musst quasi
nur so viele tasks aufmacht wie du cpu kerne hast und so was wobei es nicht
ganz stimmt wenn es iowate hat macht es glaube ich mehr auf das ist ein bisschen
bisschen intelligenter so und um das zu fixen habe ich mir gedacht wir machen
das jetzt wir waren das ganz easy wir kopieren das einfach und machen wir das
lock hier raus und wir machen hier oben eine schleife wo nur die sensoren
angelegt werden in homos ist homos ist danach machen wir ein delay von fünf
sekunden das ist ein das ist zu verkraften das läuft alle 15 minuten
und dann machen wir publish state wir machen einfach zwei sachen hintereinander
nur mit dem unterschied dass wir nicht das und das hintereinander machen
sondern dass wir das alles auf einmal machen dann warten und dann das alles auf
einmal machen und ganz im ernst das sind insgesamt jetzt jedes mal jeder nach 200
millisekunden zum verarbeiten und dann am ende noch mal fünf sekunden da hat
homos ist nicht mehr als genug zeit das ganze zu verarbeiten
das müssen wir noch
list und hier rausschmeißen das sollte eigentlich so weit passen da machen wir
hier nicht genau ins sensors excellent ja da müsste das damit nämlich auch
schon behoben sein wo wir uns dem eigentlichen hauptsächlichen problem
dieses streams widmen können also ich gehe mal davon aus dass diese ganzen
feature dinger die hier angefragt wurden das ist damit erledigt könnte man
schließen aber wir müssten ja noch den location sensor fixen und um den
location sensor zu fixen müssen wir an die home assistant api uns abrufen wo
der home assistant steht gucken ob unser auto in der nähe ist vom home assistant
und dann sagen home oder not home
ja deswegen muss ich erstmal die home assistant api abrufen dass das
funktioniert dann machen wir jetzt mal so was hier
public class home assistant api leute ich ich pretende jetzt gar nicht
aber was ein satz dass ich das jetzt aus dem kopf schreiben würde weil das habe
ich tatsächlich im vorfeld schon gebaut weil ich sonst zu meinem home assistant
gehen müsste mich authentifizieren im stream und mein standort liege und das
will ich nicht deswegen copy paste ich das jetzt mal und zeigt euch es ist
wirklich langweilig weil im prinzip ist es einfach nur sinnlose klassen mit
properties erstellt
ähm muss ich mal kurz raussuchen wo habe ich denn hier home assistant genau so
sieht so sieht das ganze aus easy
nutzt zu wim ja aber nicht für dotnet zu programmieren also folgendes ich habe
mir das schon raus monkeis ich habe mir das schon rausgesucht und zwar die home
assistant config sieht standardmäßig so aus wenn man sie abruft also man
bekommt längengrad breitengrad ja höhe name vom home assistant instanz
zeitzone und man kriegt welches es ist also welches einheitensystem also sprich
ob metric oder imperial was da eingestellt ist standardmäßig bei mir ist
es halt auf metric eingestellt dementsprechend verwende ich kilometer
und nicht meils und millimeter oder gram und nicht ounces und so komischen
bullshit aber so ist es bei mir deswegen ist es einfach standardmäßig jetzt mal
so so drinnen ja genau damit das geht brauchen wir gleich noch in der library
und ansonsten die home assistant api abfragen ist auch relativ easy
man nimmt diese magic ural die funktioniert nur innerhalb von adhans
wohlgemerkt dieser name der löst bei mir lokal natürlich nicht auf funktioniert
innerhalb von adhans und dann bekommt man wenn man da quasi anfragt aus einem
addon raus das geht nur bei einem laufenden addon in home assistant bekommt
man eben das aktuelle die aktuellen werte für die für die home assistant api
für die für die home assistant konfiguration das heißt hier habe ich
jetzt drin stehen wo mein haus steht und mein home assistant steht und das muss
ich jetzt vergleichen mit wo steht mein auto und wenn man auto im 1000 meter
radius von meinem haus ist dann wird es als zu hause markiert ansonsten eben als
abwesend und dafür gibt es eine nice library für so geo geschiss wie gesagt
das machen wir nicht machen wir nicht von hand von hand müsste man dann solche
komischen dinger machen wie ich überlege grad wie könnte man denn das
checken da müsste man irgendwo wobei es wäre glaube ich von hand gar nicht so
einfach gar nicht so schwer zu checken man sucht sich den punkt raus von den
koordinaten und dann nimmt man irgendein vector oder so was wahrscheinlich maß
vector keine ahnung irgendwie muss man dann entfernung dazwischen ich glaube
gar nicht dass es so schwer ist wenn ich mir mal da gedanken drum mache aber
warum sollte man das machen kann einfach eine fertige library verwenden
um nicht zu sagen easy ja genau und
äh welche habe ich denn da welche habe ich denn da genommen
geo api kohr nee jetzt hab sie schaab geo das da
muss halt mit bogenmaßen aber jetzt wird es high iq was du hast schon du hast
schon recht ja
du hast recht es ist ja nicht flach geolocation das ding
ja ich glaube das ding habe ich verwendet
es ist schaab klar sly breeder calculate sicher dass ich das hatte
ich glaube ich glaube ich habe das genommen geolocation hat er noch was
anderes geocoder geolocation immer dass ich ich glaube wobei ich gucke ich gucke
mal nach ich habe doch irgendwo den import geo
nein habe ich nicht verwendet leute systema nicht geolocation koordinatschap
habe ich verwenden verwendet koordinatschap exzellent es ist fast falsche
leb eingebunden obviously ja sieht richtig aus oder was sagt ihr chat
sieht richtig aus oder ich hätte es überfordert damit quick is a quick
muffs ja so muss es sein
ich habe auch keine ahnung ob das stimmt aber wenn google das sagt wird
schon so sein alles klar so jetzt haben wir den kram hier eingebunden jetzt ist
gut jetzt können wir nämlich anfangen das auszurechnen also wir wollen jetzt
wissen ist unser auto daheim oder ist unser auto nicht daheim so und an der
stelle wo der device tracker gefüllt wird müssen wir das jetzt ausrechnen
also sprechen wir distance from home irgendwie sowas in der richtung home
assistant konfig ach so die müsste ich die muss ich irgendwie mal anlegen noch
die sollte ich vielleicht mal am anfang anlegen die home assistant konfig ha
konfig gleich new home assistant api get konfig
exzellent oder würde ich sagen loggen wir die am anfang noch mal so konfig
sehr schön so jetzt können wir ausrechnen wie weit ist unser auto weg
von daheim das dürfte relativ easy sein mit der library und zwar sind wir denn
da habe ich das jetzt gelöscht oder was ist das ob ich nicht bin ich bin ich
bescheuert ich habe sie aus irgendwelchen gründen wieder gelöscht
weil ich gerade reingetippt habe aber ok also war distance from home so das
heißt wir müssen unsere home assistant konfig nehmen die ich hätte erwarten
sollen
ups
ansonsten steht da nämlich nichts drin so das heißt wir haben hier die
koordinaten von vom vom home assistant wo das steht also sprich wo ich meine
home assistant distanz instanz laufen lassen habe und jetzt kann man zumindest
habe ich in der read me gesehen von dieser library
jetzt kann man distance abfragen irgendwie distance distance distance
get distance from koordinaten koordinates so und da gebe ich jetzt die
koordinates von meinem auto ein also location wenn ich mir das mal kurz um
location
enkrad breiten krat breiten krat lenkrad location so
wie formatiert denn der das wenn ich da reformat macht das bisschen schöner wie
ich nähe sich genauso hässlich aus also jetzt sollte ich da theoretisch die
distanz bekommen zwischen meinem home assistant und meinem auto also distance
distance from home in in feet kilometer meter miles oder nortical miles haben wir
auch noch für die ganzen seefahrer unter uns das ist das ist wichtig ich
würde sagen wir machen das mal in meter so was der jetzt rauskommen soll was da
rauskommen müsste ist folgendes mein auto steht angeblich gerade irgendwo im
arabischen meer und mein home assistant ist an auch mitten im meer auf so einer
boje an 00 das heißt da sollten jetzt irgendwas um boch keine ahnung schon
schon schon ein paar kilometer rauskommen auch mal kilometer kann kann google
moment wir machen google google earth google earth
oder maps ne maps bringt mir nix kann google earth kann google earth irgendwie
distanz zwischen punkten kann ich zum beispiel sagen hier null island als man
das überhaupt findet null genau das ist nicht null null immobilien berater alter
massive benahmung
wie gibt man eigentlich
wie gibt man überhaupt koordinaten hier ein in google maps google maps google
ks null null null einfach so ach shit wie gibt man das in google maps ein stand
und liegt monke es und lenkrad suchen ja gibt wat dezimal ok machen halt so auch
ok das ok das check da und jetzt geben wir einfach null ein null kann man das
so machen null genau also da steht mein home assistant gerade da da steht mein
home assistant und wir sagen jetzt entfernung messen von da was klicke auf
die karte um ein fad einzuzeichnen alter ich will kein fad einzeichnen ok route
route von hier an landischer ozean so und ich mein mein auto mein auto steht
gerade in 69 4 endlich 99 doch 99 69 hier europäisches nordmeer alles klar und
warum ist jetzt nicht beides markiert dann dann machen wir jetzt einfach
entfernung ach hier unten jetzt ok also es sind ungefähr 7000 7500 kilometer
liegen zwischen meinem home assistant und meinem auto 7674,43 kilometer dann
schauen wir mal was da jetzt rauskommt bei da bin ich gespannt also 7500 merken
wir uns mal bin mal gespannt was das ding haben wir was es da jetzt draußen
macht ja auf geht's
auch ich habe ein bisschen viel debug ausgabe fällt mir gerade auf bis
bis jetzt viel ist gut ja komm doch hin guck mal 7000 731 das ist gar nicht so schlecht oder hat
jetzt ausgerechnet 7000 731 kilometer sind die dinger voneinander entfernt es ist ok
kann man kann man mit leben denke ich zumal es ja um deutlich nähere sachen geht so
completed gut das heißt wir wissen jetzt wie weit das auto weg ist daraus müssen
wir jetzt sagen irgendwie ist home oder sowas nie home status oder sowas machen
wir jetzt distance from home in metern so wenn das wenn das kleiner als 1000 meter
ist man kann es übrigens so machen hier wenn ich so tausende trennzeichen so man
kann jetzt übrigens so tausende trennzeichen machen das gibt es halt ein
passi schaap version ist ganz nützlich wenn die zahl länger wird ja jetzt
braucht man das noch nicht aber jetzt ist es glaube ich doch deutlich besser zu
lesen mit dem anders vor dazwischen wohlgemerkt anders war nicht punkt
punkt ist nachkommen stelle also es muss so sein das ist gemacht dass man es
besser lesen kann aber 1000 kann man noch so lesen also wenn die distance unter
1000 meter ist zwischen den zwei punkten dann ist mein auto home und ansonsten ist
mein auto mein auto not home was findet ihr besser not home oder away
bevor ihr was sagt überlegt der default wert in home assistant ist home und
not home und nicht home und away also ich würde sagen wir bleiben beim
home assistant default und das ist eben home und not home was ziemlich bescheuert
als mehr hätten es lieber home und away nennen sollen aber es ist in es ist in
homos ist halt mal so wir nennen es not home in water not in water
unter wasser müsste es ja eher sein
homo stollen
da fehlt eigentlich zu hauen stollen fehlt jetzt eigentlich diese diese copy
pasta ihr wisst welcher ich meine joe never donated never subscribed free
entertainment neighbors wifi stolen laptop mehr fällt mir nicht mal ein jetzt
nächstes feature wäre ausgabe mit nautischen meilen und knoten dafür gibt
es schon die passende library aber ich wüsste nicht wozu nautische meilen
sinnvoll wäre gibt es in homos ist in homos ist ja nicht so ein radius doch
aber das ist meistens für presence detection von leuten mit smart phones
nicht für autos und radios kann man nicht abfragen über die api das meine
ich genau das habe ich gehört never sub never donated adplug on stone laptop
neighbors wifi mamas haus stolen solar panel stolen suns solar energy stone
water wheel neighbors river das ist eine andere variante als die ich kenne
stolen hydroelectric plant charging phone in was schauer in berth das ist
eine andere copypasta die ich kenne aber gut free entertainment das ist das
wichtige dran free entertainment never sub never donated
so wir wissen jetzt ob das auto home ist oder nicht
das heißt wir müssen jetzt noch setzen in dem in dem tracker müssen wir das
noch einbauen wenn wir das mal hier dring value oder ja ja so das müssen wir
jetzt noch an homos ist in schicken das mal weg alles weg hier weg weg und zwar
welten die value soll schicken wir das nämlich an homos ist nicht als
attribute topic sondern ans state topic es klappt das nicht so und wenn ich das
jetzt ausführe dann sollte es eigentlich funktionieren wenn man es
richtig wenn man sich richtig rein folge kopiert also value gleich home status
ok der sollte jetzt not home setzen auf den sensor das sieht echt nach java aus
das ist bisschen es hat gewisse ähnlichkeiten man hat früher nicht um
sonst gesagt sie scharf ist dass microsoft java
so guck mal was mein sensor hier jetzt macht
und passbar über die config das pro dass er da hat schon guck du mal das
addon hat eindeutig not home hier not homos funktioniert not home das addon
hat schon viel zu viele kommt mal das addon hat schon viel zu viele options
schaut mal das ist in die ganzen option da blickt auch langsam keiner mehr
durch ok die sind standardmäßig ausgeplänt
hier unten
sagen die scharplein immer dass java kacke ist java ist nicht kacke java ist
nur nicht so gut wie sie scharfe java kann man durchaus verwenden ich
persönlich bin kein großer java ja genau
das sieht aus wie javascript was das überhaupt nicht aus wie javascript
das sieht null aus wie javascript javascript hättest du schon fünf mal
gleich gleich gleich drinnen gehabt ist und die feind und solche komischen
dinger
so war und da hast du recht nur mit dem unterschied dass man in javascript war
gar nicht mehr verwendet sondern eigentlich lett habe ich mir sagen
lassen dementsprechend mache ich das jetzt auch
weil verwendet eigentlich meistens nur noch lett und konst in javascript und a
weight haben sie von c sharp geklaut die javascript leute ich weiß nicht ob es
daran liegt dass typescript am start war und der typescript erfinder gleich dem
c sharp erfinder ist also wer es nicht weiß es ist der gleiche typ
ich weiß nicht wie man den original ausspricht ich spreche in anders
heilsberg aus und anders heils an das he an das heilsberg heißt da glaube ich
der c sharp und typescript erfunden und ich glaube auch noch turbo paskal oder
delphi oder irgendwie so zeug der war sehr umtriebig die letzten jahre
anders wird anders ausgesprochen kann schon sein
also der typ hier nicht heilsberg ich weiß wie man den ausspricht der
kerl ein däne turbo paskal delphi genau
so jetzt funktioniert das mit dem home schon mal jetzt mit dem not home jetzt
müssen wir mal kurz schauen ob wir es irgendwie hinkriegen dass da home steht
also wo muss denn mein auto wobei ganz einfach ganz einfach
wir lassen einfach wir stellen einfach unseren home assistant dorthin wo unser
auto steht und gucken aber ob das funktioniert wer go dieser irgendwie
heißt der typ pike oder so heißt er nicht pike der da go typ oder war das
der der der ja doch genau ja
wir stellen jetzt einfach mal unseren home assistant dahin wo auch das auto
steht das auto steht nämlich
bunker ist da da steht das auto wir stellen wir stellen einfach mal unseren
home assistant auch hin wie macht man unter linux gui ausgab gibt es da auch
windows forms nee du kannst mit mono wenn falls du mono verwenden will zwar sich
nicht machen würde kannst du windows forms teilweise unter linux laufen lassen
aber das ist abartig ja pains champ es gibt kein windows forms nee aber es gibt
das ist das beste was du verwenden kannst für c-sharp linux und cross
plattformen gui meiner meinung nach es gibt avalonia
ist eigentlich sehr schick
dass das haben die mit avalonia gebaut
ich habe gerade für einen kurzen moment gedacht ich ich würde buber strike
bekommen aber zum glück nicht ja also das gibt es und ganz ehrlich wenn ich
wirklich ein linux gui mit dort nett machen müsste dann würde ich avalonia
verwenden es ist leider xml basiertes zeug fürs gui aber gut irgendein tot
muss man sterben
ja der typ war auch sehr umtriebig dann auch überall seine finger mit dem spiel
gehabt not gatschi bass
so jetzt stehen geblieben chat was wollte ich jetzt mal also ich wollte ich
wollte meinen home assistant an die stelle stellen wo mein auto steht ja
sekunde so also hier steht hier steht mein auto und da steht jetzt auch mein
home assistant und jetzt schauen wir mal ob das ganze home ist
gut ist die beste gui naja aber nicht für c-sharp eigentlich für nix außer
für c++ und manche leute verwenden das auch mit pysen
wobei ich mir vorstellen könnte dass du da probleme bekommst wenn du ein paar
sachen erweitern willst aber das weiß ich nicht genau not home
warum ist es immer noch not home es sollte jetzt eigentlich home sein
warum ist es not home was da los
es ist not home es müsste jetzt eigentlich home sein
weil home assistant steht da
warum die bag ausgabe gucken ich glaube ich war so blöd nach die
debak ausgaben wieder rausgeschmissen oder lat und longfahrt a ja lull
korrekt das geht das immer mit koordinaten
chat ihr schreibt auch random einfach irgendwas gut und engine bestekohi
der nächste kommt mit cute an er will einen linux dotnet gui machen da bringt
ihm weder cute was noch gut gudo wenn man das genau ausspricht wenn aus
form es bringt ihm auch nix java xf java fx bringt ihm auch nix
es gibt einen emote dafür das brauche ich chatting 70 wie ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher welches das ist das da
für leute für solche sachen im chat brauchen wir dieses emote leider habe ich
nicht die möglichkeit ff 7 tvs hier gerade zu aktivieren
gibt es das auch für ffz oder benet rich tv falls es jemand findet sag mal
bescheid dann füge ich das mal ein das passt jetzt wunderbar hier dazu
also ich weiß nicht ob eine game engine das beste ist für den grü für den
cross platform grü mein theoretisch klar kannst du das damit machen weil spiele
brauchen auch menüs und alles kannst einfach das spiel weglassen nur ein
menü machen ich weiß aber nicht ob ich das keine ahnung ich glaube nicht dass
mir das gefallen würde mal ganz einfach abgesehen ich kann
einfach aber lohnt ja verwenden und gut es gibt ja schon ein gescheites
cosplay vom ui framework das in kombination ist sogar noch besser ja
gab es nicht mehr mono gtk stuff doch das gibt es immer noch aber gtk ist
schrott das einzige wo man gtk verwenden kann ist für gnome programme und der
gnome man kann theoretisch gtk oder windows laufen lassen aber das ist
einfach richtig abfack und gtk selbst zu programmieren ist auch abfack habe ich
mal gemacht
zumal es von einer mission auf die andere kaputt geht das will man nicht
brauche was ordentliches der scheiß gnome ja was aus dem geworden ist nicht aus dem
gnome aus dem typ der das immer gesagt hat das wüsste ich auch wir sind home
leute das auto ist in der garage das ist home excellent
will demnächst mal gtk mit l machen warum um alles in der welt gtk mensch
versteht es nicht gtk ist so eklig wie home now chat
ist denn so funktioniert wir können das ein bisschen schöner machen
chat ich habe eine idee wir machen das was ist denn gtk noch mal
gnome nämlich gnome gimp gimp nicht gnome gtk ist auch gimp gewesen
ursprünglich gimp toolkit oder sowas oder es ist mittlerweile gnome toolkit
gimp toolkit ja kennst du noch gbt gbt gui das ist ja war nee kenne ich nicht
kannte ich nicht und will ich auch nicht kennen gibt es gimp eigentlich noch ja
gibt es noch was blöde frage aber entwickelt das noch jemand weiter
tatsächlich da geht es ab
massive entwicklung stels
wie oft werden da sachen wie krieg ich eine kommet history in github ich habe
lange kein github mehr bedient wollte wie krieg ich den kommet history in
github da geht schon los kommets da
ziemlich aktive entwicklung immer noch in gimp sieht das mittlerweile kann man
das mittlerweile halbwegs verwenden oder ist es immer noch unbedienbar mit der
gui
installieren wir es doch einfach mal opel data wird installiert gimp
ok sieht schon mal gut aus paar mushrooms so soll das so pepega aus
schauen ok ich ich know nicht was ich was ich
du hier sieht aber aus wie 1995 auf jeden fall
kacke
bonnie alla das ist das kommt mir echt vor views ability auf 1995
der da oben ok
ich verwende weiter mein nuv programm
ich verwende weiterhin affinity designer und affinity foto und gut ist hier die
zwei dinger verwende ich auch für samtnails und alles das ist easy zu
bedienen für kacknungs wie mich und gut ist
kann jemand ein frontend für git empfehlen ähnlich geht haben gox genau
geteia oder geti wenn man das ausspricht gox nein nicht das was jetzt wieder
falsch verstehen wollte oder gox geo gs git lab würde auch funktionieren wobei
git lab ziemlich schwer schwergewicht ist an software ich würde ich guck
dir geht hier an und geht geht geht tia geht gox oder geht hier an ich weiß dass
es in folgen ist aber das ist schon gefolgt worden vor fünf jahren oder so
hat sich ziemlich unterschiedlich dann auch entwickelt
lazy geht das kenne ich noch gar nicht das ist das ist das meinte er glaube ich
nicht er meinte was entsprechend zu zu github das ist ja anscheinend irgendein
kommando zeilen gui ding
so ist es ein lässchen wie ich denke mit bucket ist ein lässchen
ach geht ne ne ne er sucht er sucht ein webservice so was wie github
er sucht keine guis lokal die einmal mürchen helfen oder oder wo man wie
nupt ganz ehrlich leute lokale git guis ist most most useless kram aller Zeiten
die einzig wahre bedienung von git ist über command line alle lokalen git guis
sind trash brauche man nicht also die anzeige finde ich okay ja also sprich
wenn man jetzt hier zum beispiel sieht aha hier hat ja wubblers committed und
so was wenn hier so was steht das finde ich das finde ich okay aber ich würde
nie im leben comiten rebasen pullen sonstiges zeug über meinen editor
machen ich mache das alles über command line ist finde ich das beste was es
gibt würde ich würde ich nicht mal ich meine es kann jeder machen wie er will
logischerweise aber ich nicht ich verwende git rein
cli und gut ist da weiß ich wenigstens was passiert
cli beste ja da hast du recht das ist tatsächlich nicht verkehrt ein tool
für diffs das lasse ich mir gefallen wenn man das nicht per cli und wim machen
will ja das verstehe ich muss ehrlich sagen ich persönlich mache vieles über
cli und wim auch diffs wenn es ein bisschen länger wird oder wenn es
vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt was ist was ja wenn es irgendwas ist mit
ordentlichem idee support wo man das braucht so okay man kann auch wim diff
verwenden wobei ich damit nie richtig warm geworden bin ich bin tatsächlich
jemand der marker aus dateien löscht von hand
manchmal manchmal verwende ich ein tool aber
visual studio kurz für diffs auch okay ja aber zum größten teil entferne ich
tatsächlich marker aus der datei und sagt so soll es am ende aussehen und
alles von hand also ich verwende tatsächlich geht nur
per cli zu 99 prozent vielleicht mal ein tool zum für merge konflikte wenn es
ein bisschen was größeres ist und unübersichtlich wird aber ansonsten
99 prozent cli und sogar merge konflikte löse ich quasi fast immer mit wim
alles andere braucht man nicht und in dem fall ist es nicht gemeint mit alles
andere braucht man nicht so nach dem motto boomer sagt braucht man nicht ich
finde es ist das beste das über cli zu machen besser als alle möglichen
git guise und tools die es da sonst noch so gibt
warum auf der konsole rumtippen wenn man 20 button gibt weil du dann weiß was
passiert drück mal den rebase button in deinem in deinem editor und versucht
da mal nachzuvollziehen was er genau getrieben hat richtig das ist genau das
problem der kommet button wird vielleicht das tun ja aber du weißt
nicht was er unter der haube macht
lass den user selbst entscheiden was dort stehen sonst sonst standart home und noch
noch noch ein ich weiß nicht noch eine option mr. film meinst du wirklich das
wird jemand verwenden ich meine es doch ok das heißt home und not home und
darauf kannst du dann reagieren mein meint es will wirklich jemand
customisieren ob da home oder not home steht
zumindest den radius
genau den radius customisieren lassen ok also wir können das wir können das
machen aber ganz im ernst 1000 meter ist doch vollkommen in ordnung ich meine
man ist mit dem auto wenn das auto innerhalb von 1000 meter radius ist dann
ist das daheim wo sollen das sonst sein bei der
nachbarin in der garage oder wo wo soll das auto sonst stehen auf der straße
davor ok aber dann ist es doch auch zu hause
wenn der radius variabel sein soll da musst du auch wieder auf einheiten
aufpassen warum wo denn weshalb ich meine es ist in meter
wenn manche mit meilen arbeiten wollen ja das ganz im ernst also wisst ihr was
wir machen können also wenn schon wenn schon dann richtig wenn schon wenn schon
dann richtig dann können wir auch das parsen was jemand im front end
reinschreibt da kann dann jemand zum beispiel reinschreiben was ist denn wenn
im front end dann jemand reinschreibt 400 23 yards oder sowas was soll ich dann
machen ich bevorzuge auch crashen und sagen verwendet gescheite einhalten wir
bleiben bei meter wir bleiben bei meter also ok weg wir können das machen chat
wir könnten das mal also konfig wobei das wobei das ist aber optional ja das ist
das ist ob optional optional also wir können quasi sagen
und was haben wir was haben wir das war das andere noch mal home home home
ne home text home ja label label kann man nicht haben und label so schreibt label
so oder oder so schreibt ja was denn jetzt btf ok label oder label label ist
korrekt ok also home label und home radios kann man angeben
was für den adler per hamburger ist die einzig wahre einheit
als nächstes pakete im brief tauben home label not stimmt das brauchen wir
auch noch ok ok home assistance rest ab was kann man da alles abfragen
vielleicht kann man ja auch die dort definierten zonen abfragen also konfig
kann man abfragen konfig sieht dann so aus was das ist das das ist das das
unicode zeichen für diesen diesen kreis da grad Celsius
oh zürich kommen patrick bei dir irgendwo in der nähe zu zürich zirk und flecks genau
kann man kann man über die api irgendwie abfragen was für was für zonen definiert
sind da könnte nämlich zum beispiel auch das auto auf der arbeit angezeigt werden
und so was wenn man die zonen abfragen könnte
events services browser keyboard states wie wie definiert man überhaupt im
home assistant zonen zonen ja doch da mario du du du du du du du du du zonen
hier 69 jetzt kackel so die kackel zone ist das hier mitnehmen ja so
und wie fragt man die zonen ab bestimmt mit services das muss jetzt mal ausbringen
weil dann könnte man sogar anzeigen lassen das auto ist auf der arbeit oder
so das ist gar nicht übel muss ich mal kurz nachgucken also wie fragt man die
home assistant api denn überhaupt ab köln gibt es ein köln example vielleicht köln
so musik ist ein bisschen laut
so home assistant endpoint 1 2 3 2 1 3 2 endpoint ist slash api slash services
so unauthorized wo kriege ich denn ein token dafür jetzt her token wo bekomme
ich ein token hier wurde dann youtube kanal gehackt oder warum kommt da nichts
mehr naja nichts ist vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben das letzte video
ist glaube ich zwölf tage her wir wollen es ja mal nicht übertreiben
oma also das kann man glaube ich nicht nicht nichts nennen oder aber es gibt
bald wieder was es ist eher umgedreht ich wollte gerade sagen sehr umgedreht seit
der kanal gehackt wurde gibt es wieder was lul nichts wäre nach zwei monaten
erkennt mich in einem halbes jahr und dann ist immer noch nichts wo kriege ich
jetzt hier so ein komisches tauchen her bei johr tauchen you can obtain a long
lift axis tauchen bei logging in der front end und use your profile ok mache
ich ich use ich use mein profil tauchen
ein langlebige zugangstoken erstellen ok teckel tauchen massive tauchen
und jetzt da hey funktioniert und leak und nein
wartet mal
kann man nicht sagen dass er color und jetzt minus er jawohl heckermans am
start hier gibt es jetzt saun saun ok und wie frage ich services services jetzt
ab
post ne das was anderes
also wirklich schlau draus werden was die jetzt wollen werde ich jetzt nicht
will you turn when the service has been executed or after 10 seconds
muss ich states vielleicht gucken states
wie kriege ich der meine zonen hier raus zonen
da sind wir doch excellent excellent ja nice guck mal so kriege ich sogar raus
ob das auto auf der arbeit ist das ist doch nice das finde ich gut das
mal klein bauen saun in welchem array ist das drinnen in einem riesig langen ok
wir suchen nach entity all dies die mit saun anfangen alles klar man liegt so
deine koordinaten gar nicht das ist ein fake homo system den ich nur verwende
für den stream da ist nix drinnen was ich liegen kann
ist doch heute ist doch heute stream titel also ich muss jetzt dahin ok das
bauen wir jetzt mal nach programm ich mache das gerne im stream so was leute
ihr kommt immer auf gute ideen ist ernst gemeine tatsächlich lob an den massive
hi iq cutest cutest chat auf twitch da wäre ich so gar nicht drauf gekommen
also wir wollen jetzt wie heißt die uhr ja states wollen wir callen states get
jason essen gachi bass tauchen zwar mit diesem tauchen mit diesem tauchen
ja warte so das müsste eigentlich jetzt hinhauen
so mal gucken was da jetzt rauskommt ob ich das jetzt ordentlich abgefragt
bekomme ups run ob das der als output kommt warum could not be deserialize zu jason warum
kann das nicht deserialize werden wo ist das problem
ach das weil es ein array ist weil das ein array ist wahrscheinlich
schon funktioniert weil es ein array ist das muss das muss man ja auch wissen so
und jetzt will ich was machen select mehr wehr select tokens geht das wehr jetzt
will ich gucken entity id heißt der krempel hallo max schau deiner seems gerne und finde
dich richtig gut aber sagst du zu eigentlich c++ und in c++ krähen wir hoff sage ich dazu
mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen es reicht aber auch so entity id ist dieser krempel
entity id ok machen wir es mal so
ne select
gucken ob das ob das sinn ergibt was da was dabei rauskommt so da sollt jetzt theoretisch
eine liste bei rauskommen mit allen entity ids zum beispiel auch sowas wie zone zone
keckel da ist es doch nice so wir holen uns alle entities raus wo die zone startet mit
also wo die entity id startet mit zone punkt ob das funktioniert ja aber zone keckel und
zone home haben wir am start excellent theoretisch könnten wir noch eine weitere option eingeben
zonenname für die home zone oder was auch immer nice guck mal jetzt haben wir das hier
jetzt haben wir die 2 zonen ja das ist ziemlich nice die sharp ist doch eigentlich nur c++
mit ein paar zusatzfunktionen oder chat chat ihr könnt mich heute nicht chibaden in eine
c++ diskussion egal was ihr versucht das wird heute nix was mit der zone passiert damit
ich rufe mir jetzt ab lenkrad und breitengrad und dann gucke ich ob mein auto dort ist und
wenn mein auto dort ist dann zeigt mein device tracker an den friendly name der zone was
eigentlich
macht auch einfach wenn entfernung zur zone unter ein ja genau das genau das das das mache
ich jetzt auch genau das mache ich jetzt auch ich zeige euch jetzt mal ein nice tool wer
das noch nicht kennt das könnt ihr bestimmt gebrauchen ich weiß es gibt idees die sowas
eingebaut haben aber wenn man nicht hat dann bin ich das hier ganz praktisch guck mal du
kannst auch gleich den radios nutzen für was was wie guck mal man kann hier jason rein
pasten und er generiert einem dann dort leitklasse draus das da brauchen wir nicht das da brauchen
wir auch nicht steht mit in der zone drin aus der radius der zone achso ja aber das ist
für ne das ergibt ne ne das ist blödsinnig das gilt für fußgänger also standardmäßig
stellt man das ja ein für für presence detection von personen also sprich haben die ihr ihr
smartphone dabei das ist fürs auto passt das glaube ich nicht gut dann hast du ein bisschen
größeren hof und das ist auf jeden fall nicht daheim und sowas ne ne ne das machen wir lieber
lieber konfigurierbar ok also ach hier kann man gar nicht drinne schreiben ich copy paste
mir das mal schnell
das da eigentlich hier rein wobei das mir ein bisschen zu voll wird ich glaube das muss
ich mal langsam aufsplitten guck mal hier ist das ganze haumassisten zeug drin das ist
länger als das hauptprogramm lull so das ist haumassisten zone das ist das ist haumassisten
zone attributes excellent so freund name icon ist gut editable brauchen wir nicht persons
interessiert uns persons nicht wirklich oder was muss ich was muss ich wissen ob da irgendjemand
zu hause ist oder oder nicht oder mir egal passive radius ja das ist ok so das reicht
mehr brauchen wir nicht so jetzt können wir das nämlich parsen lassen hier also wir haben
einen array und da holen wir uns jetzt raus select ne wer entity id start mit zone guck
mal das ding wie schön da hinkriegen select tauchen tu kann man das ding wie karsten zu
objekt haumassisten zone marko ob das prinzipiell tut was ich hier mache select zu haumassisten
zone kann man nicht das einfach importieren hier moment habe ich das habe ich das ausversehen
ich habe das ich habe das in line auswärts eingebastet da sollte das nicht hin so so sollte
das sein so schauen wir mal was da ist rauskommt ja gut das geht nicht es kommt da raus
passt leute fast funktioniert es freundlin im ach so mein serializer checkt es mal wieder
nicht der ist zu pepega jason die property name oder so man kann auch mal mich müsste
eigentlich die fall settings mal umstellen für den serializer ich kann ja nicht überall
so einen so einen attribut hin machen id sonst checkt das nämlich nicht und freundlich
und freundlich name ist dann freundlich name so und jetzt sollte es auch funktionieren
zeigt mal her im setting am besten ein zone radius offset dann geht er nicht nur größer
sondern auch kleiner wenn man in der garage steht ja können wir machen da da hamas massive
state null ja state brauche ich auch nicht state kann weg weiß ich was state in dem
fall heißen soll config home radius ja haben wir doch haben wir doch haben wir noch eingefügt
so also da haben wir das und jetzt bekomme ich die zonen infos von home assistant zwar
noch relativ eklig aber ich bekomme die zonen infos von home assistant das kapseln wir noch
in der eigenen class aber jetzt net weil was ist bald chat was ist in einer halben stunde
allem schon ist bettge time bettge bettge bettge bettge bettge ich muss ins bett
pen schon spät genau so jetzt können wir das mal schnell ausprobieren ob das von der
idee her so funktioniert was ich da gebaut habe zwar heute produktive vergleich zu sonst
schon ja so wo ist denn der device tracker da also wir checken jetzt nicht wir checken
jetzt nicht distance from home sondern wir checken wie man das jetzt
fast fast ok die erste zone wo
oder ich ich muss noch mal eine sache anpassen sonst muss ich jedes mal den kram selbst man
copy paste mir das mal ich ich bin jetzt ich bin jetzt einfach mal faul da muss ich das
nämlich nicht selbst jedes mal legen so die koordinaten wo die koordinaten quasi distance
from car location ist das da distance davon unter tausend meter ist tausend meter
was hat er jetzt für schmerzen sollte man jetzt so anstellen das ist eh nur quick and
dirty hauptsache kann jetzt mal gucken ob das geht massive zeilen denke da hieß 120
zeichen so also die erste zone in der sich das auto befindet so wir wollen aber first
or default haben oder wollen wir aber first or default haben home assistant zone meinetwegen
also alle zonen zones gibt schon ich will einfach nur testen ob es funktioniert also
alle zonen in denen mein auto drin ist ist in der regel ja null oder eins oder bei distance
first alter six hat heim leute das ist eine gute idee das ist eine gute idee oder bei
moment ich muss kurz überspringen ich muss die distance ja erst noch mal hier exportieren
weil die distance jetzt jetzt kommt link link magic leute new distance oder zone magic
oh nee geht es so nett das muss ich vorher machen select jetzt jetzt wird es aber advanced
hier select was jetzt schon wieder wo achso public static brauche ich noch nicht mehr
so wer hast du sag mal bin ich jetzt zu zu zu blödem was ist was hat denn für ein problem
also wo ist das problem funktioniert doch habe ich irgendwo was nicht geschlossen oder
so ach hier klar ja das muss tatsächlich noch weg das ist richtig wer geht doch wo
ist das problem das hatte eben für schmerzen gehabt
ja geht doch also wer distance meter ist schon in meter unter 1000 oder bei distance monka
es alter was ein ding was ein ding er das ist halt so hässlich da muss ich mir etwas
anderes überlegen so als haben es ordnet bei distance die zones und jetzt können wir
schauen homestatus genau also distance vom home ist in dem fall ziemlich egal wir wollen
jetzt eigentlich nur gucken ob in den zonen was drinne ist so alter meine idee ist abkacken
monka es zones haunt oder nie hässlich any any dann ist es zones first zone attributes
friendly name und ansonsten ist es ja not home halt unknown oder unavailable oder sowas
away away es ist away dass er glücklich ist das müsste eigentlich so funktionieren
ich wüsste mal kurz aus das müsste eigentlich einen moment moment
ne doch doch ist richtig ist richtig aber das können wir so nicht lassen das ist abartig
als fakt was ich hier gebaut habe was schön an so was macht away das sieht schon mal gut
aus leute away wobei sollte es eigentlich away sein habe ich irgendwas vertauscht eigentlich
sollte es doch home sein oder sollte es nicht home sein aber die back car location und ja
dann dann mal die zones kurz eigentlich eigentlich sollte da jetzt nicht also ich mein prinzipiell
sieht man schon mal das was funktioniert aber sollte da jetzt nicht home drinnen stehen
weil er die home home zone gefunden hat schaut mal ich muss das debug bisschen kleiner machen
und get home assistant konfig ja nicht schlimm nicht schlimm
er findet keine zone warum denn habe ich irgendwas falsche rum wieder habe ich wieder irgendwas
falsch rum habe ich wieder irgendwas falsch rum home assistant zones so
und home 42 ne tatsächlich der ist nicht home zone home ist doch ganz woanders dann muss
ich mal kurz mein auto verschieben mein auto ist nicht bei 16 nein mein auto ist jetzt
nämlich in der zone keckel ist mein auto viel besser kann man testen wenn ich wenn ich sage
das auto ist jetzt genau das auto ist jetzt ich kann es eigentlich einfach gut das vier
das genauso schreibt alles da so und jetzt sollte mein auto in keckel stehen wenn das
funktioniert postchamp postchamp präge chat präge jawoll funktioniert mein auto steht
jetzt in keckel das funktioniert so das wäre ich morgen wahrscheinlich auf stream noch
ein bisschen verschönern weil so wie es jetzt ist wirklich abartig af guckt euch das immer
an hier allein schon dieses link statement also erstens finde ich mittlerweile nix mehr
hier das muss ich ein bisschen aufräumen ich meine dieses link statement ist schon irgendwie
eklig da gibt es sicherlich schönere varianten aber es ist ein gutes beispiel für wie man
relativ easy mit link so sachen abfragen kann und sortieren guckt mal stellt euch mal vor
ich hätte es von schleifen mit hand machen müssen von hand machen müssen da sucht jetzt
alles wo in welchen der listet alle zonen auf wo die wo das auto quasi innerhalb von
1000 meter radius ist und dann sortiert er sie nach entfernung müsste ich nicht machen
oder bei ne ascending ist schon richtig das ist eigentlich ganz cool da haben wir heute
richtig was geschafft aber schön ist es nicht muss ich morgen noch irgendwas ausdenken morgen
muss ich erstmal nach frankfurt auf die arbeit fahren und morgen mittag vielleicht bauen
wir einfach morgen mittag zusammen weiter auch keine schlechte idee was machst du bei
meilen wieso also das mutig mal einem auch einem cona unit user zu dass er das mal für
die config in meter umrechnet es könnte so einfach sein wenn die gesamte welt einfach
meter verwendet aber nein das geht ja nicht müssen ja noch so ein paar länder besonders
freie einheiten verwenden bei meilen ist es ganz einfach wie gesagt er sollte es halt
in meter umrechnen bei den koordinaten ist es egal da ist es immer in meter aktuell
ist es hardcode 1000 ich meine ich könnte jetzt noch ein freitextfeld anbieten dass
die leute da reinschreiben welche welche entfernung und dann passt das quasi das value
also man könnte zum beispiel units oder so verwenden haben wir letztens schon angeguckt
man kann es dann das parsen kann es dann quasi sagen pars kilogramm und so ein shit da könnte
ich sagen pars längs längs pars kuck und da kann er dann zum beispiel jats und so was
mal ausprobieren kommt mal schnell noch mal aus sich nur mal so just for fun nicht integrieren
das programm wir haben noch kurz haben noch kurz zeit einfach mal gucken ob der ob der
so ein bullshit wie 1000 jats oder so ob der das ob der das parsen kann richtig als die
amis wieder durchdrehen und da komischen chat eingeben so also längs es geht jetzt auch
über die app pass gibt es try pass ja zum glück pass string jats ob nicht kalender
week hallo hä warum kann ich jetzt nicht so und das ganze dann in angströmen bitteschön
ja ja 1200 jats bitteschön in dezimeter das genau das brauche ich was ich da mache
ich gehe jetzt eigentlich gleich auf wie am moment was ist die abkürzung für jats
jr jr ne console log beste jats jd jd ausgeschrieben ist es nicht advanced genug für ok 1000
jats ok und das jetzt konvertiert in angströmen in angströmen alles da was zum teufel ist
angströmen für eine einheit das angströmen nach dem schwedischen anders jonas angströmen
ist eine maßeinheit der länge arme trinken ein angströmen entspricht dem zehn millionsten
teil ein wow das aber klein also chat ihr wolltet sicherlich schon immer wissen 1200 jats sind
ich habe keine ahnung wie viel angströmen oder was realistisch ist in meter in mega
parsec ja das ist tatsächlich dann quasi nichts in mega parsec war parsec nicht entfernung
sonne erde ne parsec war lichtjahre ne was war parsec noch mal ne sonne mond ne sonne
erde sind irgendwie astronomische einheit oder irgendwie sowas moment was ist parsec
ist eine astronomische längemasse aus welchem der mittleren erdbahn radius sag ich doch
abstand sonne erde unter einem winkel von einer bogensecunde erscheint alles klar
warum sind 1200 jats bitte schön 3,5 ach nee minus 20 ach so nee ist es nicht es ist
ganz ganz wenig da kommen einfach noch mal 14 nullen davor ok verstehe ja dann 14 nullen
2 minutes was das bogensekunden oder was monkeis nix für mich alles klar der fußballfelder
geht leider nicht das wäre es wäre gut das wäre für deutsche deutsche library wichtig
ja ok leute nice waren wir heute tatsächlich relativ erfolgreich
also mit planklängen könnte man lossless in jede andere einheit umrechnen nee lossless
auch nicht du kannst es gibt zwar keine kürzere logische also nichts was sinn ergibt wenn
es kürzer ist aber du kannst mit was kürzerem rechnen und dementsprechend kannst du auch
nicht lossless lossless umencoden also physikalisch mag es keinen sinn ergeben rechnerisch kannst
du trotzdem was kleineres machen fußballfelder wären auch eine fläche und keine länge das
ist wohl richtig wobei die zumindest eine höhe und eine breite haben müssen oder eine
länge und eine breite oder je nachdem wie man das sieht alles klar leute wir sehen uns
beim nächsten mal bis dahin bis dahin bis dahin bis dahin bis dahin bis dahin bis dahin